you saw [ __ ] all this [ __ ] the blast
and by the way
deservedly so de blasio was getting
because obviously nobody was you know
there was there was no there was no
crowds allowed
um on new year's
at all because you know it's the
covet is killing people so there was no
you know obviously
nobody was allowed to be at times square
the most famous new year celebration not
this year covet
not this year except if you're the mayor
mayor bill de blasio is receiving some
pretty heavy backlash after the new york
city democrat posted a video of he and
his wife
dancing in times square on new year's
eve
this after the mayor and police told new
yorkers and anyone thinking of traveling
to the big apple for the holiday to stay
away and watch a virtual version
of the ball drop from home do not come
to the area if you think you're going to
be able to stand there and watch the
ball
you're mistaken usually one million
people pack the square to bring in the
new year
this year because of the coronavirus
concerns a large force of police
officers barricaded the area to stop
anyone who was unauthorized from
gathering so when people saw the mayor
and his wife dancing in an empty time
square
it sparked outrage on social media
he posted the video himself this is the
to me again
he put that by the way that cop was
something else but whatever
there's a lot to break down but so he
posted the video
himself
you should this entire city that i'm
laughing look i'm laughing not because i
don't care of course i care about i care
about people i don't want people but i
hate but you can't understand something
for me it's very fun
because before all this before all this
coveted [ __ ] and all this stuff have
you watched my show or rotc
or even before that i've been very clear
i hate new york city new york city i
hate it
i hate new york city and i hate new
yorkers
sorry i know some of you new yorkers
you're cool i guess
but i hate new york city
and and and seeing them
seeing these new yorkers being mad now
because they can't go to their little
restaurants and they can't do it
because of the people they keep voting
into this city
is is you know what it is here
actually as a matter of fact
um i haven't used this in a while so let
me let me
let me pull it up and pull it up i uh
[Laughter]
here let's watch this again while that
while i pull it up the crap posted a
video of he and his wife
dancing in times square on new year's
eve
this after the mayor and police and
anyone thinking of traveling to the big
apple for the holiday to stay away and
watch a virtual version
of the ball drop from home do not come
to the area if you think you're going to
be able to stand there and watch the
ball
you're mistaken usually one million
people pack the square to bring in the
new year
this year because of the coronavirus
florida people are no better than new
yorkers
spoken like anybody who says that is a
[ __ ] angry new yorker
florida people are better than new
yorkers
in one way we didn't shut our [ __ ]
state down
and the governor that we voted in
is letting people work so that being
said
florida man wins again take the l
[ __ ] take the [ __ ] l new yorkers
because you deserve it
take the [ __ ] l um
so yes i hate seeing people suffering i
want these people to work i do
but but me seeing these [ __ ]
cocky just up their own
ass new yorkers who are always thought
they're
all [ __ ] better than you they're all
better than you
vote these people in that are literally
literally
dancing with glee while they can't go to
[ __ ] work
or their little hipster cop the coffee
place
well i'll tell you what it is it's kind
of funny
it is it is kind of funny so
take that [ __ ] you new york
i hate new york the way thomas murphy
hates taylor swift
new york you ruined my day you ruined my
day
i'm gonna go put some hand sanitizer in
the microwave
if new york is so great why the [ __ ] do
you ada why new york is so great
why the [ __ ] do all you move here like i
think
florida you know what it is
new york's just [ __ ] for example if
you're a woman
or whatever let's say let's say single
woman right and you move to new york
when you're 18 i'm gonna go to school at
a big apple i'm going to the big apple
the [ __ ]
yeah great for you once you hit like
35 and if you're still in new york
single
you've you've new york is the spinster
city it's where you go to be a spinster
like after a certain age if you're still
there it's
new york you know what new york's like
new york's like high school
after a certain age if you're still if
you're still in high school
you're the problem so
[ __ ] you i'm happy i'm happy he's
dancing
you vote these [ __ ] in you vocomo
and you vote this [ __ ] and you vote
them in
and now they're dancing in an empty time
square well you're stuck in your
[ __ ] six thousand dollar a month
studio apartment because you want to be
i hear this all the time you want to be
where the
action is i like big cities
it's where the action is
is it where the action is because it
sure seems it's like whether you're
[ __ ] told what to do
and you pay more taxes than almost
anywhere in the country except maybe
places in california
maybe maybe and that's soon to come
because como says he wants to raise
taxes he does he's already said it so
this isn't like you know he's already
said that he's looking to raise taxes
they should have stormed times square
are you kidding me the [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh new yorkers are also [ __ ] by the
way this tough guy new york act this
this spider-man new york guy you messed
with one of us you messed with all of us
is such [ __ ] [ __ ] that's not
they protect new yorkers haven't been
like that since
scorsese's new york okay that big
tough guy new york thing doesn't exist
anymore new yorkers now are
frappuccinos and and [ __ ]
fedoras and nine hundred dollar scarves
okay
it's not the crayola baby
that's not that doesn't exist in new
york new york now
is just filled with hipsters
losers and that's what it is
so if you want to live there that's fine
that's your prerogative
but you now after coronavirus you're not
allowed especially new yorkers you're
not allowed to talk [ __ ] about florida
any [ __ ] more
at all because there were places that
were packed here on new year's eve
people were partying beach party
it was [ __ ] bananas and over here
in new york you sting a little stupid
that's the way we hear about new yorkers
it's like
yeah i know my place is small and i pay
a lot of money but man i don't you know
i i just i don't i i don't live in new
york just to be inside like oh i go to
my i go to my little apartment to sleep
but when i walk out the door
it's hustle and bustle it's the new york
city
new york city hell yeah guess what now
you're stuck in your little six thousand
dollar a month prison
and you're not allowed to go outside and
hustle and bustle and your little
favorite
yoko's the best food good luck go eat
outside in three degree weather you [ __ ]
faces
you voted for it congratulations now you
have
in the biggest city on earth suck at
dick new york
and you know what let me be clear new
york city i have no problem with upstate
i have no problem with upstate all right
upstate guess what
reprieve you get a reprieve from this
but new york city
you can suck a dick
i felt good i felt really good i'm i
felt real i'm
just so sick of hearing new york this
[ __ ] that
justice this cocky [ __ ] new york
attitude and now you what do you explain
yourselves new yorkers explain why i
would want to live there why is everyone
leaving your [ __ ] city
huh
i don't care about buffalo i don't
really rip on buffalo because if you've
been to buffalo it's so
sad like and not sad and like i'm angry
at them sad it's just sad it's like
it's basically canada so i mean if you
live in buffalo i'm sorry
i'm really sorry you have to live in
buffalo
uh hey look you guys beat the [ __ ] out
of the dolphin so congratulations
why people go to places like asian stuff
they're revered right they were [ __ ]
revered they're like oh my god look at
them look oh tall white blue oh
you know the stuff they're loved like
they're loved now that's you if you're
from a free state if you're from like a
texas south dakota or especially florida
go to new york now
your royalty because you're allowed to
go they they walk up to you like
what are restaurants like we've
forgotten
what are house parties like we don't
know what it's like
please explain to me person that comes
from a free land
from it's you you sho you're from
florida you show up in new york you
basically you could
it's like coming from narnia they don't
even understand
and i know this because when we have the
the the the road rage thing
i had a lot of people from new york and
a lot of people california
[ __ ] freaking out going this [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] this is crazy i love this
so basically yeah it's not difficult
because we come from narnia
and um we are people we are the free
people of the world
uh so thank you so thank you
uh
new york has more cities than nyc
and buffalo royce only knows them
because puerto ricans
i literally said i'm fine with upstate
someone's not paying attention
he must be from new york
you could tell until new yorkers only
listen to themselves
i do a show with one so you know i know
that uh
[Music]
the free state of florida that's correct
the
free state of
florida
i have a little coffee here uh i don't
normally don't drink coffee so i might
be a little amped
the f in florida is for freedom the l is
for
lots of freedom the o is for oh my god
i'm so
free the i is i'm free in florida
the d is damn it's nice to be free in
florida
and a is hey
i'm free in florida see perfect
do you like that make an acronym of
anything bull body
bull body all right focus
we get it no
no you don't uh
boy he's hopped up on coffee yeah i'm so
[ __ ] straight edge you literally have
to get that coffee to get myself going
no r in you know what i missed it
and you know what the r is for hey
remember there's an r in florida because
we're free here
boom see what i did
brought it back brought it back